is wild that the new
the nato line is now at the border of
communist russia
like people haven't put that have put
that framework into their brain yet if
you think back to like east and west
berlin where like
germany
was the forefront of western
civilization and democracy and
capitalism was in berlin and then on the
other side of berlin was russia
and then the wall came down
yeah mister
tear down this wall guess what that has
been encroaching
inch by inch
and that's it's in belarus
it's so bankrupt it's so sorry to say it
it's so 20th century bro hey putin are
you are you annexing territory again
they are doing this are we going back to
the [ __ ] twenties they are though i
know but nobody's doing anything work
out i know no one's going how did it
work out he's literally he's about he's
gonna go all the way the port you mark
my words
they're gonna get ukraine's going to be
a landlocked country 80 percent of their
gdp happens through that port they're
screwed yes now poland
finland romania
are all on the chopping i think that he
would be asking for and you would know
more about this than i do by far but i
think that nato has the weaponry and
technology to decimate a serious russian
assault in a place like poland because
they remember this if they attack sure
they attack and they just took ukraine
but nato's a huge difference ukraine is
not a nato member the minute they step
[ __ ] foot in a nato right and that's
why putin said in 2012 the idea that
that that ukraine is flirting with nato
membership
is so antithetical to our it is it is a
direct assault on our national security
and if you think we're going to have
nato weapons on our border you're
certainly mistaken well now they have
nato weapons on their border yeah they
do he literally the hypocrisy of him
saying like i don't want nato on this
calculation
no he did exactly what he thought he was
going to do he just moved instead of
having nato come to his border he moved
his border to nato
so in in the aggressor
he's not dumb he's not done he's not
done they also say he only has three
years to live yeah he's fine
yeah and do i do what a tyrant can do in
three years that's what i'm saying yeah
i mean i could get a lot done if i was i
think it's scared that he was three if
he actually has three years i think he
wants to be this is a fancy bottle yes i
could use this as a weapon yes welcome
to thick boy yeah
he could kill somebody with that oh yeah
or the mic
but i think what's scary if he does have
three years he wants to be like cemented
in history yeah so what's him
going to stop him from releasing the
news well i don't think there's any
profit in that right so so i think he's
he's he's a cold calculated guy who's
looking at the like there's a there's a
strategy and a method to the madness
right so now ukraine belongs to me now
ukraine is no longer going to be a nato
member right and
there's probably some there's probably a
lot of
profit in something like that where you
can control history and profit though
because the oligarchs are on the [ __ ]
run now and they and the old guards
control everything i'm sure there's a
cost for skin analysis of like what is
this land worth what is the production
that's happening on the east side what
is this poor port worth like 80 percent
of a country's gdp is that more than
i think what happened to oil prices when
russia i need a flow chart for me to
make before i start making decisions
about how deep into this country i'm
going to go i'm i would be like all
right so i would take this manufacturing
this industry i would take this
uh mining i would take this amount not
stupid no